welcome back to las vegas now besides
fresh school supplies you know we love a
fresh school fit wendy albert from
miracle mile shops is here to give us
you know what back to school fashion
trends are going down right now and i
have to say i already see my look over
there and i cannot wait for you to break
it down but first and foremost what's
your favorite that you're seeing out
there right now that people are shopping
for i think the greatest thing is
individuality like college students they
want to be their own person right and i
think that's the great thing is that
there's so much options out there
everybody gets to wear what they like
perfect okay so then let's get into it
because we've got three very different
looks three different vibes where are we
starting let's start with riley riley is
wearing h m from top to bottom and what
is great about this is layers so she's
got a great t-shirt the ac dc t-shirt
which i'm not going to say i saw in high
school but i multiple times saw them in
high school and then she's got a hoodie
young game girl and then like the jeans
the distressed jeans which are so great
and those wonderful boots i love those
boots so it's great she can wear all
these together she can wear them
one-on-one um and then she's got the
cute little messenger bag which i mean
everybody needs to have one of those
i have to admit that i mean this is an
outfit i would wear right now we can
make that i love it okay let's move on
let's move on okay and then tomboy
and then cozette is wearing from guests
and guests the great thing about this is
this is a beautiful way to kind of move
into fall but not look totally small but
also this would be fun to wear this
class and then also to wear it out with
your friends and she's got a block heel
which is super comfortable and easy to
walk in and that bag you could throw a
little laptop in there and not have it
look just like any other school bag
exquisite and then you know i don't know
about high schoolers wearing that but
nowadays they might be that
[Laughter]
and then last we have tyler and tyler is
wearing lululemon and whoever says
athleisure wear is not still in is
completely wrong i know saying that so
this is all from lululemon and he is
wearing the softest absolute t-shirt i
have ever felt in my life and that comes
in all different colors
and these are like that jacket is
waterproof it's windproof and he's got
some really great cozy pants so um i
think he's set i love this look honestly
my favorite fashion tip is girls you
guys can rock the men's wear absolutely
the boys wear yeah for sure okay let's
get to the table let's do this so the
other thing about college kids is they
don't have a ton of money so we got you
covered there too so right here we have
from morphe this palette that has every
different shade you could possibly think
of
27
for this whole thing right and then over
here we have some vegan brushes from
them and then some setting spray and
again i was saying how these everybody
can do makeup much better than i can but
this is a limited edition coconut flavor
or something i should say not flavor so
this is a great look from morphe i
haven't figured this part out yet i need
to buy some because my wicker is always
telling me you gotta use studies spray
i'm like i don't need it i know it seems
like one extra step but it's a great
product
and then from key australia we have a
bunch of sunnies and the wonderful thing
about their sunglasses they start at 55
so you could have a sunglass wardrobe
and then also the all-important blue
light glasses so that when you're all
the college kids are staring at screens
all day protect your eyes protect your
eyes do it young and then the last thing
is the raider image gave us a great
backpack and i think that if you're
going to have you know be individual do
it with your bag too so not just throw
any other bag and they also have these
limited edition raiders hats you can
support the team while you're in school
super cute i put that on with that
eighth and dc fit and i'm ready for
school okay and last but not least here
you know just a couple a couple stores
at miracle mile shop that you're seeing
everybody shopping at for back to school
all of these h m lululemon um also
guests and then also that we've got
great stores from everything you could
possibly think of steve madden aldo if
you need shoes everything you need all
right everything you need miracle mile
shops thank you guys look fabulous i'll
send it to you